préparer les élections législatives
président caennais revient de le dire
c'est une affaire importante et je me
tourne vers excellente député des
yvelines
il va falloir coexister intelligemment
parce que si on ne colle pas
intelligemment c'est ce jeune homme qui
va ramasser les qui va cesser d'exister
intelligemment ça veut dire
bienveillance ans passés à une autre vie
relativement simplement ne pas se
détruire et
le l'élection au scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours exige de pouvoir se parler et
si l'on ne se parle pas on prend des
risques considérables dans ses discours
part d'ombré de cette caf emmanuel
macron dans son discours il a mellow
très clairement tendu la main à nos
atouts il les force de winglets mais ce
serait mieux s'il y avait un système
politique plus ouvert qui pourrait
concilier la france avec les démocraties
parlementaires européens
[Musique]